good evening 19 children were shot dead
at school in Uvalde Texas yesterday they
were all under the age of 12 slaughtered
in their classroom an 18 year old Maniac
who just bought the guns he used for his
18th birthday present
these children's parents took them to
school yesterday morning their young
hearts joyful with excitement for
another day of Education and Fun with
their friends
but they never went home and they're
never going home and those parents will
never recover now from the loss of their
children
they were slaughtered by this 18 year
old lunatic he was then shot dead by
police
in the deadliest School masochist in
Sandy Hook where 20 children or six
adults were killed in another senseless
tragedy that devastated the world that
was 10 years ago
and what's changed
well nothing is the Staggering answer
America's endured more than 900 school
shootings since Sandy Hook including 27
this year alone
in fact there would be more mass
shootings in 2022 in America than days
of the year so far
some politicians like Senator Chris
Murphy from Connecticut where Sandy Hook
happened
can't understand why
what are we doing
why are you here this isn't inevitable
these kids weren't unlucky
this only happens in this country
he's right whichever side of the gun
debate you're on America has a uniquely
hideous record for gun deaths and mass
shootings against the world's richest
countries only in America should mean
the opportunity for any person to Aspire
to be anything they want to be in the
most successful country on Earth it
shouldn't be the mournful event we hear
every time a maniac opens fire and
innocent children in a place that's
supposed to be happiest and safest
history doesn't have to repeat itself
but we're mass shootings in America with
school shootings it does again and again
and again and the big question is why
Steve Kerr who's the coach of the Golden
State Warriors basketball team one of
the biggest names in U.S sport spoke for
many last night
since we love shooter on 14 children
were killed 400 miles from here
and a teacher
and in the last 10 days we've had
elderly black people killed in a
supermarket in Buffalo we've had Asian
church goers killed
in Southern California and now we have
children murdered at school
when are we going to do something
but it's a very good question isn't it I
understand he's anger and passion not
least because his own father was killed
in a terrorist attack in Beirut so he
understands pain and grief and loss
I also understand a few issues I was
impassioned or as divisive in America as
guns it's not for me as a non-us citizen
to tell Americans the laws that they
should have
I learned the hard way of the Sandy Hook
that a British accent shouting about gun
control to Americans goes down about as
well as an American accent telling Brits
to abolish the monarchy would go down so
let me say this instead I understand and
respect the constitutional right of
American people to own guns under the
second amendment that was a right
ratified by the Supreme Court in 2008
but surely there must be some things
that all parties can agree on opponents
of new gun laws say they wouldn't stop
shootings because criminals will still
get hold of them but by that logic why
have any laws against anything
we have laws against murder but we know
it won't stop all murders we just hope
it will reduce the number of murders
the shooter Salvador Ramos legally spent
five thousand dollars buying two AR-15
semi-automatic rifles and 375 rounds of
ammunition just a few days after his
18th birthday
and yet he couldn't have legally bought
a beer in Texas for another three years
Kinder surprise chocolate egg anywhere
in America because they're banned over
the choking thread of the toys inside
you don't have to be Pro or anti-gun
control to realize this is battlingly
inconsistent just as it seems absurd
that there's no law enforcing Universal
background checks on all gun sales when
91 of Americans in the polls want them
to happen
and those background checks must include
all potentially relevant information
Ramos was known to police after violent
arguments with his drug abusing mother
and firing BB guns and we now know he
posted his plan to attack a school on
Facebook before carrying it out
the supermarket shoots it in Buffalo New
York Peyton Gendron was also 18 when he
murdered 10 black people in a white
supremacist Rampage just 10 days ago
he bore his guns legally too and was
also known to police after threatened to
shoot up a school the Sandy Hook shoot
at Adam Lanza was 20.
and banning people from being able to
buy guns until about 21. won't stop all
young men like this get in their hands
on guns but shouldn't we at least make
it more difficult for them
there were calls today for more armed
security at schools
we know from past experience of the most
effective tool for keeping Kids Safe is
armed law enforcement on the campus
Senator Crews may have a point I don't
disagree with making schools more secure
but the Texas shooter was engaged by an
armed School guard before he even got
inside the guard was shot and Ramos
carried on his attack
so the answer to these endless massacres
can't always just be more guards or more
guns which another leading cause of
death for U.S children overtaking car
accidents think about that
Texas already has about twice as many
registered guns as any other U.S state
more than a million of them are
registered the guns didn't stop this
tragedy they caused it it takes a
mentally ill monster to Gun Down
innocent children but it's also
monstrous to what happened time and
again and do nothing isn't it
America is a magnificent country with
great people I've lived there and worked
for nearly 20 years in the United States
and I love the place but the level of
gun violence is spiraling out of control
the massacres are getting worse and more
frequent it just can't go on like this
toxic partisan Point scoring which
erupts after every one of these terrible
atrocities achieves nothing
nor do the thoughts and prayers of
people in the aftermath
nor do liberal celebrities screaming
abuse at law abiding conservative gun
owners
a set is for Americans to resolve this
gun violence crisis not people like me
who are not American
but all I will say tonight is the
bullet-ridden bodies of those poor
innocent children lion mortuaries is
that surely surely doing absolutely
nothing to prevent this happening again
can no longer be an option
we started this show tonight with the
story of the 19 children who was shot
dead at their school in Nevada Texas
these are those children they were all
under the age of 12. they were taken
with two of their teachers I want to
take a moment now to tell you the names
and ages of every single one of these
victims so that we can all fully
comprehend what has happened here
the Sea of Garcia was eight a Granddad
described him as the sweetest little boy
I've ever known Javier Javier Lopez was
10. he was bubbly and loved to dance
Emery Joe Garcia was 10. her grandmother
said she was super outgoing and a
teacher's pet
and a bellaguada Lupe Rodriguez was 10
years old she was an exemplary student
Nevaeh Bravo's cousin says she's flying
with the Angels Above
ten-year-old Ellie lugo's father
described her as a doll
and was the happiest ever
Rogelio Torres was 10. his cousin said
it breaks my heart to say my Rogelio is
now with the angels
test Marie mata's sister called her a
precious angel
Lexi Rubio was 10 and was described as a
bright light in everyone's life
Jose Flores was 10 and loved to laugh
and have fun
JC Carmelo Louis villanos who was 10 and
Jayla Nicole suguero who was 11 were
cousins
the mother of Jayla said of them fly
high my angels
ten-year-old Matie Juliana Rodriguez's
cousin described her as a sweet smart
little girl
ten-year-old alethia Ramirez's dad said
she loved to draw a wanted to be an
artist
11 year old Miranda mathis's cousin said
we loved you dearly I'm so sorry this
happened
McKenna Elrod was 10. her sister told us
all to hug her loved ones tight tonight
and tell them that you love them
Eliana Elijah Cruz Torres was 10 her
family said she didn't want to go to
school on the day of the shooting
ten-year-old Jackie casares her little
sister portal online that she was sorry
she forgot to say good morning today
two teachers also died 46 year old Emma
Garcia who taught at the school for 24
years and had four children along with
44 year old mother of one Eva marillas
I took my ten-year-old daughter to
school today it was just an art
exhibition day with all her friends they
were all 10 11 the same age as these
kids that were slaughtered yesterday in
Texas
I can't even imagine what those parents
are now going through other than I've
spoken to Sandy Hook parents to dumb
blame parents I have some idea but it's
the ultimate unimaginable horror and
once again I just say to America a
country I love do something about this
please for the love of God we have got
to stop kids being slaughtered in their
classroom
that's all for us tonight
thank you